what's up guys were here with the
official Bane character breakdown from
nether realm now this did come from a
developer livestream so if you see
something weird remember that it's a
work in progress and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for all the latest injustice
to character reveals and breakdowns that
a flash in vain are really great
examples of returning characters that
don't play exactly the same they have
new specials different tweaks done to
them so that they don't seem exactly the
same but they're familiar
Ronnie played them preview what you
liked about bane and flash is back but
there's just a few things to spice it up
so one of the first differences is his a
1-1 to Street alright are we gon' the
there we go alright right so now he can
- gates you can actually hold it the
last card oh yeah
and you can - gates a lot I can do it I
can do it yeah we do ok I'm sorry
no you can now in the original you can
just do one on two but now you do one
one two hold down and going overhead
or you do one one - you can - out so you
can fake them out
he also has four - now had a bunch of
options has a new one which I absolutely
love for now he steps on your back
brakes Batman's back from a way as if
Batman couldn't be body by being anymore
Deena has this and the second part is an
actual Brett it actually counts as a
threat
he also has a new standard throw wriggle
haha big chokeslam and he has a new
command grab the bank vault which I
absolutely mr. nasty
powerbomb man Peter Brennan you can't
this is my favorite oh no we're out on
another everybody so awesome yeah he
also has a new meter burn for his venom
uppercut which is like his big entire
attack Peter Burman and your opponents
will rust in peace of mountains Bam Bam
that's beautiful super sweet he also has
a new overhead attack and mercenaries
helmet which has a really cool beater
overhead attack it's very good use of
his dom 1 or any of his strings or just
use it off a jump in and then you meter
burnin man a big old brain buster I love
it let alone so he seems to have more
wrestling move boy as we closer than
ever right wardrobes of his character
power is back which is three levels of
venom and you gain a damage buff putting
blue put both and armor on all your text
catches once it runs out your debugger
and then everything slowed down
don't have anything so the idea is you
use it when you think you're going to
get any chocolates going and D buffs out
that's when it's time now it's out now
look at this yeah yeah you can see this
bloating this is by - right like it's a
lot of trouble huh and writing
damage-wise like this usually does
little so then the idea is uppercut
levels a level three venom Bane is
arguably beast on this character in
degree but a debuff he's seriously
weakened and that's what his long range
comes to play you can see his down one
his forward to his back - so very far
you know he's a really nice brightness
so he's very good at keeping the
opponent out and then he's very good
when he gets in as long as you're
managing about a level scrunt the name
of the pain bothers graphing like heaven
like all the characters to guess is your
super and this super is really cool it
is equal screen ground-pound
biggest DDT up bringing through the
atmosphere that was so clean dual screen
I sure can
this is a great win so would you have
full bar super if the opponent moves at
all of you see they're going up so beta
is one of the characters we play
drastically change Lea's four bar if you
have to be very very careful so if
you're a character that keeps paying out
like doctor fate or Deadshot it done
when he has the four bars all of a
sudden you don't do a fireball you're
going up for that DS and you have four
bars and he has three tanks on open
you're losing a lot a major damning
major dami okay that is bait in a
nutshell I would say really cool out of
high web there is nobody like we've
talked about like if you were a
character loyalists back in the day
their character they'll be like go back
into but still learn anything yeah I
felt that with Fang yeah I knew what I
was doing but there's some new tactics
I'm running into that I'm trying to
employ as well right like the cancel
thing which I love it's a terrible ask
leave the elbow which is awesome oh yeah
that's one of my favorites what I'm
expecting coming like it and then you're
like just kind of lands it yeah let's
show we made some cool costumes okay
gear part I am I love bein skier I think
it's very very cool
well this is like and we talked about
the venom the venom
so there we go is now all in blue and
everything to go so this is another just
one of his sort of epic Pierce Nets we
really liked um being quiet and careful
yeah yeah well vane is known for a
stealth notice yeah
so let's show some of the lanes we got
for this move list let's look at the
movie I run them down and I don't I
always never look at that joke oh yeah
yeah yeah juggernaut Rush is a really
cool one Michael screen it is a Russian
grab it is armored so it'll run through
attacks and then slam you down
if I had control of the character I
would try and do something right it's
all right
sure you would yeah I mean I probably
jump around like an idiot domestic
you'll just have to imagine
ah let's go Eriksson some power yeah so
oh he cut him up
well you know oh ok ready 1 2 3
OOP that did not work so maybe steam is
wrong well bees it will this is that
early look at vain so this is what
happens when Derek it's controls is he's
growing well that's what I was here to
do is the show that off we noticed that
dude oh yeah yeah but I'm still doing
yeah fair enough
that was a great showcase of famines
battery yes
so that's gigantic rush good day on
those well like I just did saw that and
then you also have wait what I think I
actually know why you let me get super
shot which other which is a perfect this
is the perfect example this is hype
Steve okay this is not a fail and tell
them why supercharged is one of his
abilities and this changes is character
power instead of gaining armor she gains
an even bigger damage boost so the idea
is if it's a matchup that you're
comfortable that you can get in on that
you're not going to be kicked out you
sacrifice your armor and look at the
damage well do one of your big compost
okay go to level three and do a combo oh
that's yeah
all right be buffed very hard trying to
get take to Hector everybody see my
problem it has another mother man in
trouble when I you gotta you know well
even look at that yeah I mean that's
huge
yeah yeah so this is a very risky
trade-off and if you're confident that
you'll need the armor you can do massive
amounts of damage can you do is super do
that do soo yeah D level you give back
in full life okay I would be so
terrified yeah
I would not absolutely that's a good
ability now the thing is there though
like with Bain when you want to use that
the armors one case giving it right you
are without and that's what that's the
cool metagame is the armors one of those
powerful twos tools to get in close
you're not going to happen
yep cool it's not another set of gear we
have set up for him I'm going to load
out another loadout good call that's
what we call though that's what we
should go with there your else that you
can do that we have air top rope here
top rope is Air Ground Google limbs them
down you can do it off a combo
and you can be Roberta jumping up there
God God okay yeah
so that becomes a going to anti our tool
a good combo tool and it also looks
awesome juiced up and shows is that look
at the ass just like that looks great
yeah that's really cool so and then the
other ability we have is if you liked
the wake up options you got an injustice
one with the body press you can choose
to use the old injustice body press
great for Batman back again yeah that's
why I chose Batman everybody that better
Atlanta that's why yeah that's Canon so
he gets us in just this one can is
around back so you can decide which is
command grabs you prefer and just like
flash this is a little preview of his
abilities there are still more others
for when you get the game
awesome awesome so let's go take a look
at us here again and we will we get a
little talking so Steve yes what
happened last week at the end of the
street if I recall correctly you
defeated Derek